[Music]
over the past century the ocean has been
rapidly changing global water
temperatures have increased sea levels
have risen and the fundamental chemistry
of the ocean has been altered the
biodiversity that appear on these are
three and a half billion years ago now
our pressing threat because of we the
humans a marine biologist in the Bay of
Bengal is investigating the resilience
of marine life by researching one of the
planet's greatest survivors the
horseshoe crab they've outlived the
dinosaurs and survived mass extinctions
can their ability to adapt provide clues
for how other ocean creatures might
evolve and survive in the face of modern
day climate change we believe that
because those who could have survived a
whole the information for survival
[Music]
in the northeastern part of the Indian
Ocean is the Bay of Bengal dr. Pinette
smokey Bihari and his team of marine
biologists are searching for horseshoe
crabs but finding these creatures is
harder than it once was seems to be an
interesting place where he should be
able to see some horseshoe crabs
horseshoe crabs are an example of living
fossils they've existed nearly unchanged
since at least 445 million years ago
long before dinosaurs there are keystone
species which means they play a crucial
role in maintaining the health of this
coastal area partial crabs in sizeable
numbers can help accelerate many of the
ecosystem level processes transfer of
energy maintaining the food wave
ensuring the carbon cycle so therefore
they are very very critical but they are
now on the threatened species list 10
years ago when I started my work looking
at the horseshoe crab population at this
place I'd find lot of horseshoe crabs
today I see hardly any horseshoe crabs
the team is researching what is causing
the decline in population to help build
a case to make part of this coastline a
marine protected area we are using with
Fisher for communities they get hold of
the horseshoe crabs which are caught in
nets or in trawlers they pass those
horseshoe crabs to us so that they can
recover they can help towards
conservation by keeping an eye how the
habitat is changing or how they are
being threatened but the team is facing
many challenges
horseshoe crabs are sought after because
of their ability to improve human health
they have a unique substance in their
blood which is used to make a chemical
called Lyme Ellis amoeba site lysate
this chemical can detect trace amounts
of bacterial contamination it is used in
many vaccines and to test equipment
before surgical operations as a result
the blood of horseshoe crabs is one of
the most valuable liquids on earth and
can be worth as much as $16,000 per
litre although they return to the ocean
after being bled an estimated 50,000
horseshoe crabs died in the process per
year but this isn't the only threat
they're facing like so many other ocean
creatures the horseshoe crabs are also
being affected by overfishing coastal
pollution and habitat loss perhaps the
greatest threat however comes from
climate change over the past few hundred
years human activity has increased the
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere this traps heat most of which
is absorbed by the ocean causing it to
warm in 2019 its mean surface
temperatures were 0.77 degrees Celsius
warmer than during the 20th century and
in turn the sea levels have risen the
ocean also absorbs carbon dioxide from
the atmosphere changing its chemistry
these factors are affecting ocean
species many will need to adapt or face
the threat of extinction today the
researchers are taking water samples and
sediment from the bay to analyze back in
the lab
what they find on expeditions like this
can shape their understanding of the
effects of climate change or marine life
like the horseshoe crab we analyze
different environmental parameters to
understand the health of this ecosystem
for example charismatic species such as
the horseshoe crabs we can then start to
link and understand what kind of changes
might be happening to them the samples
are analyzed for Sidda t temperature and
microscopic algae food for many sea
creatures including the horseshoe crab
using this information the researchers
are able to build a more accurate
picture of the biodiversity in the area
and ultimately which creatures are
likely to survive this isn't the first
time that the horseshoe crab has had to
face major climatic changes it has
survived five catastrophic mass
extinction events but current changes to
the ocean are happening much faster than
ever before human pressure is affecting
the health of the modern ocean on a much
shorter scale
therefore the horseshoe crabs are not
finding enough time to add up to these
changes and thus they are becoming more
vulnerable along the coast the team has
unearthed something unexpected the
horseshoe crabs are moving into
different areas in search of new food
sources and new habitats we are quite
happy found two horseshoe crabs out
sharing these mangrove pads they are
looking very healthy new habitats out
here within the mangroves of similar
bands where they are colonized and we
will continue to monitor this sides very
well and get an understanding why they
are colonizing these new sites the
horseshoe crabs a survival specialist
but it's too early to tell whether this
recent migration and adaptation is a
masterstroke
[Applause]
this is a fight bed mechanism or I would
say an adaptive mechanism I believe this
is a very very bold step the horseshoe
crabs are taking they're going into
areas where food resources are a very
different nature we have to keep
studying them to understand whether it
is a wise step for them or not
I'm sure knows of what it is doing
question is are we allowing that animal
to let the change happen so that it
survive and prosper the horseshoe crabs
aren't the only marine species which are
trying to adjust to climate change for
the past two decades
lobsters along the coast of North
America have been slowly moving north to
colder more favorable temperatures and
researchers have discovered that some
Arctic sea birds have moved their mating
season to earlier in the year when food
is more available the hope is that if
given enough time many marine species
will be able to adapt to the growing
changes in the ocean if we can
understand what kind of adaptive
strategies they have undertaken we can
then see for many of the other
endangered species how would they cope
to these changes that is happening in
the global ocean horseshoe crabs is
showing signs that they may adapt in the
face of climate change but to give them
a fighting chance
dr. Bihari is lobbying local government
to implement more marine protected areas
along this fragile coastline to protect
and conserve these animals and the
ecosystem from overfishing pollution and
construction
eventually in the coast of India we will
declare ecologically sensitive areas
where human induced activity will be
completely stopped
so that horseshoe crabs will survive
thrive and in the process many other
marine organisms will survive and thrive
so that is the approach that we are
aiming to achieve in the long run as the
ocean changes it is unclear which
species will be able to cope but by
conserving and studying one of nature's
greatest survivors scientists like dr.
Bihari can gain a better sense of how
other marine species might migrate adapt
and evolve in the future
[Music]
hi I'm Claire and I directed this film
if you want to learn more about some of
the innovative ways people are trying to
tackle the challenges facing the ocean
then click on the link on set if you
want to watch more of the protecta
series then click on the other link
please remember to subscribe and thank
you for watching